hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting chess puzzle uh just a
simple meeting to you guys can probably
solve it over breakfast but it started a
lot of trouble on Twitter I uploaded it
this morning and there's so many uh
interesting and colorful Solutions are
are popping up a lot of people are
having some uh fine ideas but uh as of
course not a lot of you use Twitter I
thought I'd best upload it here so you
guys will enjoy it as well so as usual I
rarely upload puzzles but when I do I
suggest you don't just look at the
comments you don't just you know load up
the position on your engine uh pause the
video try to solve it yourselves or even
print screen this printed put it on your
refrigerator you know bring it with you
to your friends so maybe they can enjoy
it a little bit as well as that's where
we really learn and that's where
progress really comes from but you know
if you've already done that and you've
just returned to this video uh that's uh
the position and of course it's a white
the mate into as the title suggests but
one of the things that a lot of people
got wrong they thought that black was uh
pushing upwards and that white was
pushing downwards as all of the pawns
are already seemingly on the second rank
but whenever I present puzzles at least
on this channel white is always on the
bottom black is always on the top I've
made a couple of um maybe videos where
where it's the upside down but very
rarely do I do this and you can see the
rotations it's A1 B1 C1 A2 B2 C2 A3 so
white is going upwards back is going
downward so all of these pawns are
already uh prepared the queen or tonight
or to Rook or the bishop so of course
black pawns go this way and white ones
would go upwards even though there
aren't any white pawns so that's the
position it's white the mate into there
is only one solution there is not 50
Solutions like people have found on
Twitter so there we have it uh feel free
to pause the video and solve it while I
give you a couple of seconds but you of
course can take
um a however much you want
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible maneuver and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen to F3 that's the move uh of
course um You probably tried all of the
checks you of course saw that the bishop
Discovery was possible but none of the
ideas actually work one of the one of
the nicer ones is let's say Rook to C2
which check uh the the one of the nicer
ones from Twitter and then of course you
have to capture Queen capture 78 or you
could block with Rook to C4 but uh still
it doesn't work Queen captures and G8
and now uh people on Twitter were saying
Knight to C1 Checkmate but of course the
pawns capture this way so that is not
Checkmate the only way to actually win
this uh is to go Queen to F3 so Queen to
F3 and now uh you are definitely
threatening some discoveries so uh how
can you how can you proceed from here
well uh there's really not all that much
if Queen captures an F3 then Rook the E4
is Checkmate uh just opening up a nice
Discovery here and there's nowhere to go
for the black king if you don't capture
with the queen you could also capture
with the rule it doesn't matter now Rook
to G for his Checkmate you have to
prevent the black queen from capturing
the bishop and G8 and other than the two
captures uh you really have no good way
of handling this because it's impossible
to stop
um uh a discovery from the bishop one
might argue okay let's play Queen
capture sanjiated this also now prevents
any discoveries being made but now uh
the possibility is Knight to B4
Checkmate so I mean whatever you do you
are getting checkmated but it's
important to play uh this uh Queen to F3
move first because once we deliver this
Knight the B4 Checkmate the queen on F3
is also guarding the Knight on A3 if
this wasn't the case we could just play
Knight to B for checkmate right away but
then King captures an A3 that's the
problem the Knight will also block the
bishop here but once the queen comes to
F3 then it's a different story than
whatever black plays now Knight the B4
is Checkmate as the queen is uh covering
the Knight on A3 I don't know if there
are even moves that we should discuss I
mean we you could also Queen any of the
pawns I mean to try and stop it somehow
you could play like B1 Queen uh doesn't
matter if you play B1 Queen okay now you
are guarding some squares you are
guarding the B4 Square now Rook the C2
is Checkmate so I mean anything you try
here there are so many possibilities for
black uh but once you find Queen to F3
and it's really not an easy move to find
very very few people have found it on
Twitter so for those of you who actually
pause the video or you know closed the
video and you know save this position on
for later on your phone or you just
enjoy it with your friends for a year
and then just came back to you know
finally give us the solution uh there
you have it if you if you have done this
and you know you haven't just seen it in
the comments feel free to write the
solution in the comments but don't uh
write something first like you know uh
maybe two sentences says you know hello
everyone this is the solution that I've
come up with so you know people just
don't glance at the comments and see the
solution right away I don't know I I
have no other ideas on how to prevent
people from actually seeing it I will
also you know write something and pin my
own post so people don't see your
solution right away but that's pretty
much all I can do so yeah that's the the
crazy position I hope you guys enjoyed
it it's really uh brought a lot of chaos
on Twitter so hope you guys had fun with
this one as well I would like to thank
Rod Hill Leonidas medical yeah Frederick
has done Christ of Mark and the animated
chemist for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it if you guys uh uh would
like I will also include a video first
link in the description below by uh the
gentleman the animated chemist uh who
made a video about the value of chess
pieces so it's been a while since we've
seen something like that to do check it
out if you enjoy it uh you know maybe
check out his channel as well you never
know what you guys might find and enjoy
way so once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it uh uh I already thanked
everyone so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day